the happiest time in my father's life
was the saddest in mine I was living
100% the life that he wanted me to live
rather than the life that I wanted to
live and he was pumped we'd go out to
get lunch like 2 days or 3 days a week
he got to you know brag about me to his
friends and that was it for him every
time I talk about opening a business he
was like yeah yeah yeah like go to
business school and then you know
whatever it took me 6 months from when I
thought I wanted to quit to when I
actually quit and so finally I basically
left without telling anyone and I called
my dad when I was halfway across the
country cuz I drove to California and I
called him up and I was like hey want to
let you know I want to start that
business and he was like all right well
come over we can talk about it and so I
was like no I'm I I can't he was like
why I was like I'm I'm in Ohio right now
he was like what